This is the first time we have come across the topic of learning in this course,
so let us examine it a little bit more closely.
We are all interested in asking the question, how do agents learn?
But this question is not isolated from a series of other questions.
What do agents learn? What is the source of their learning? When do they learn?
And why do they learn at all? For the purpose of addressing what goal or
what task? Now here is the fundamental stance that knowledge
based AI takes. It says that we'll start with a theory of reasoning.
That will help us address questions like, what to learn,
when to learn, why to do learning? And only then will we go to the question,
of how to do the learning. So, we reasoning first, and
then backwards to learning. This happened in production systems.
When the production system reach an impasse, then it said let's learn
in order to resolve this impasse from episodic knowledge. So once again,
we are trying to build a unified theory of reasoning, memory, and learning
where the demands of memory and reasoning constrain the processing of learning.